lots of major celebrities I'm talking
about doing these benefit concerts Elton
John Rolling Stones and of course tan
mom she used it with all the stars yes
all the stars yeah she and her music
partner Adam Barda recently did their
own coronavirus benefit show it's called
Quarren tan contra by the way was
covered by the New York Post they called
it a total flop a total Isle that's high
praise you know what kind of is like at
least it was something congratulations
tan mom your concert was a total flop
like that's harder than I thought you'd
get let me tell you what I know let me
let me let me set this up if you will
the plan was to raise money for tan mom
to buy her own tanning bed they also
promised some of the proceeds some would
go to a charity called God's love we
deliver of course Tan mom thought it was
good love we deliver yeah Shirley were
you covering this whole fiasco the whole
Tan mom concert I mean I watched parts
of it you know it was amazing anytime
she performs I will watch JD SATs with
the entire concert well how long was it
seven minutes too long it was like a
little like 45 minutes almost an hour
how much did it cost for an hour of Tan
mom uh five dollars I ended up paying
ten because I bought two tickets so how
many tickets were sold JD do you know I
don't know I want to say like maybe over
a hundred ten dollars worth and to be
exact I think you JD was the only guy
who bought tickets so here I've got some
tape to share with you the concert led
off with a sizzle reel of tan moms
appearances on talk shows and in the
news trial
Krenzel persevered it just couldn't
escape being tan
her partner then tried to talk to tan
mom but her audio was terrible
did you guys like that that sizzle reel
that was the sizzle reel for tan moms
Patricia's new reality show called from
tan to 10 do you like that what is this
10 to what tend to 1 to what tan - 10 10
he can rob a new reality
the first song they sang on that big
concert was tan moms newest release
glossy all you could hear was Adam and
the track
[Music]
after the song time flash tamam flashed
her tits to the online audience really
yup I was changing it because I spilled
something on it and the camera was right
there like whatever was an accident
the next song they performed was their
huge head free to be Adam saying the
entire song himself
you
[Music]
Adam tweeted out a screenshot showing he
sent 420 dollars to God's love we
deliver a great charity by the way I
want to say we did this for charity and
I want to say good fella's deliveries
they are amazing
I mean God's love we deliver I'm sorry
guardhouse and shiver Thank You JD how
many phileo fishes do you give it out of
five filet-o-fish is being the best I
would give it I mean Tim I'm such an I
like just a present I'll give it three
out of five flop by any stretch of the
imagination but I think it went up up
one whole fillet of fish when she showed
her tits
[Laughter]